[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the uh
indiana hoosiers 4-0 right now their
head coach is tom allen who joins us on
the program coach congratulations how
surprised are you that you're 4-0 right
now going into the ohio state game
well thanks dan appreciate you having me
you know um
i'm not going to sit here and tell you
i'm surprised because i'm not you know
our team has built into this point for
the last several years uh i'm sure not
everybody agrees
with my assessment but uh in terms of
our locker room and our players
if you talk to them they would give you
a similar response your voice sounds
about
eight games into a season not four games
into a season coach
you got to take care of that voice yeah
i need to but i don't do a very good job
of that i do quite a bit of yelling
you do do the players understand like if
you yell
do the players know they're in trouble
or they're they're just that's how you
you coach them well they'll know the
difference i'm usually pretty loud
in general but it'll change in tone when
it's
not positive but uh i just i like coach
with a lot of energy
so i do a lot of communicating with our
team and try to reinforce
the good and the bad well also no fans
so the players can't say hey i didn't
hear you coach
that's right they can hear everything
now
what did you think when you watch the
ohio state tapes
it's impressive you know the thing that
jumps out to me is just
justin fields i mean he just he never
hardly throws any incompletions i mean
it's
it's amazing how he's so accurate and uh
he's just playing at an extremely high
level you know they're always every year
we play them
um they look similar in terms of they're
just so big and physical
a lot of great athletes scheme is really
really good
very well coached you know so but you
know when you got a player like jessica
that's why i thought last year's team
was different
than the previous teams we played
against uh because of his ability to
throw the football so accurately
so effectively and in his athleticism is
his elite as well so
he's what makes them really really
special i think makes them different
than when dwayne haskins was there
yeah because he can run it and throw it
you know dwayne was just a
passer and the run-through wasn't the
same whereas now
you have the the passing ability uh and
the running ability that i think is
is extremely high level so it puts a ton
of stress on the defense
what is your message do you already know
what you're going to say to your team
before they take the field against ohio
state
i got an idea it kind of builds
throughout the week i kind of you know
take a lot in pray about it ponder a lot
of things
figure out what they need to hear at
that moment obviously if the preparation
matters more
than that final you know charge to our
team but
but at the same time you know we got to
play with the ton of confidence and
and uh we just got to go there let it
rip you know it's a great opportunity
for sure but we're playing the team that
uh
in the end hasn't beaten very frequently
in the past maybe you should watch uh
miracle on ice with her brooks and get
that speech and maybe uh
maybe sprinkled that in your kids might
not be aware of that speech coach so you
could sample from herb brooks and maybe
uh
maybe i'll resonate with your kids yeah
you never know but uh
i don't think our guys think it's gonna
take a miracle we just gotta play our
best football
why not an eight-team playoff this year
if you look at
you know what you guys have been through
college football has been through you're
not sure how many games you're going to
play it's not going to be the summer
now same number with the sec and the acc
and big 12.
isn't it really crying out for an 18
playoff this year yeah i would have to
agree with you on that one i think it
would make a ton of sense
uh there's so many things there's going
to be so many inequities with
everybody's schedule
number of games played and how do you
decide what matters or how do you
what number do you come up with uh when
the kids have no
control over any of that so it'd be a
perfect time to
expand it to that number so it doesn't
look like that's going to happen but it
sure would make a whole lot of sense
what was that feeling like in the locker
room when you beat penn state in
overtime
it was unbelievable you know just uh a
culmination of a lot of things you know
this is a
room full of guys that believed in the
vision that we had for this program even
when many did not believe
and these guys did that's why they came
here coach of staff included and
so it was a special special time it was
uh it was a great great feeling
and one i'll never forget it's one thing
when you're a coach and you see one of
your players out there injured it's
another thing i'm sure when
you look out there and you see that it's
your son thomas a reserve linebacker who
got
injured what's that like as not a coach
but a parent when you're watching what's
going on
yeah it rips your heart out you know
it's just uh it is a little different
you know i have to be honest with you
when it's your son
um and i i didn't know at the time how
serious it was but when i got out there
and our medical guys whispered to me
that it was a dislocated hip i was
i couldn't believe it i knew that was
serious injury and so
my heart just sank because i knew this
season was over and obviously even his
whole future was in jeopardy so
uh but you know he's a tough tough kid
and and you got to be able to separate
the two but man i love him my whole
heart and
and he's a special young man we've been
through a lot together so but he had
surgery yesterday
and he's on his road back to recovery
yeah it's one thing for you
you gotta you gotta coach your game how
did mom feel about that uh
watching that's really hard well you
know it's all the travel and everything
so she wasn't even at the game and so
i had our dfo caller immediately uh
because obviously she saw what happened
when watching the game but didn't know
the details and just tried to get her to
to be able to
to stay informed and so that made it
really really difficult on her for sure
so but uh
it's part of being in this profession
and part of being what we do we've kind
of learned to
gotta have thick skin you gotta be tough
how many jobs have you had
uh this is my 11th school that i've been
at that includes high school and college
so
number 11. yeah and you were at
newcastle high school right
that's correct that's where i went to
school played for my dad couple years
after steve alford
yes he's five years older than me i was
a seventh grader when he was a senior
and he would pack so you watched him uh
in that gym what's that gym c
ten thousand ten thousand unbelievable
high school arena how about that ten
thousand
pounds only got twenty thousand what was
it like to watch steve alford in high
school
oh unbelievable yeah every game was sold
out um
i'd sit there and we had keep track of
this they didn't have a three-pointer
back then so i keep track of all of his
points
all the shots all of his free throws he
never missed any free throws
unbelievable
but his dad was a head coach for
basketball obviously and so
uh yeah pretty special time he was so
fun to watch and uh i've always looked
up to him
i wonder what would he have averaged
with a three-point shot back then in
high school
we averaged 37 without it so you had to
think it's got to be
mid-upper 40s which is unbelievable yeah
well who's the biggest name out of
newcastle high school
steve alfred oh okay well if you beat
ohio state
yeah well hey you know
[Laughter]
uh congrats i i'm old enough to remember
when indiana
was competitive back in the 80s i think
the running back
was mike harkrader and i think he ran
for a thousand yards
coach corso was there i go back a long
way
now i grew up an ohio state fan but uh
i i remember when indiana used to be
okay but uh you've brought him back
i mean this is more than bringing him
back this is something indiana football
hadn't seen
in uh a long long long time so
congratulations on that and uh
and good luck against ohio state thank
you dan i sure appreciate it have an
awesome day helio that's tom allen